you
one is jariyama chess calm and I just
got paired up playing a five-o game
Sicilian on board let's try and open
Sicilian
more experience playing Bishop b5 than
anything
all righty let's try Bishop to e2 and
we're going down a very theoretical path
I'm not so knowledgeable of this I know
I need to get my F pawn rolling
let's get that in there that is um no it
seems a bit awkward
huh
I'm wondering if I could try so
caveman-like
let's do let's start with some maybe
King there he is put the King here
yeah I may go for something like this
now that I have something to bite out
okay and how about we start with first
Bishop to e3
I'll be playing Bishop to f3 soon I have
to cover for my knight is not challenged
and what now let's start with cleaning
one
actually on this kind of idea is
possible now
all right so they're just throwing in a
media punch I have to jump in here
I like that I'm on d4 it's an additional
benefit of the queen on TV one she's
pretty flexible piece I may want to
scoop that guy up
okay well that changes things I have the
bishop pair now but yeah at the same
time I guess I'm dropping d5
I think that's the end of the world but
yeah they're definitely up upon here
turn out to be a thorn and now I will
have a son play along the D file I think
at least let's just get right here I'm
missing something it's the night gonna
drop into this square
possible
yeah that is a bit annoying actually
okay well how about we put the bishop
here
guard the c8 square c2 could be
vulnerable and now at least my queen is
guarding III but certainly prefer to
play this position not down upon but
okay we're going to still keep the
bishop here
watch out on that square
five might be something
yeah they're just going to push this
pawn down let's see let's start with
Queen g3 Knight to f5 yep
see me to get something going all right
let's get this replying
maybe check provoke this and then a
later f5 could be something I need to
create some open lines now I'm just
going there straight away hmm
where are the tactics
I'm not sure
build up some more
- they
maybe a move they're playing very fast
that is for sure
whoo okay let's defend this guy
then Knight to h5
hmm
I should have appreciated that be for
advance a little sooner huh not liking
this position
okay well I think I have to do this I
feel like they could just go pawn
hunting some more with night to h5 we're
going to see
now they just push this interesting okay
who Knights ready to jump in here
I guess we're going to go here
right here into f2 you know this is just
lost to try to stir up some trouble but
I don't really see how how I manage that
there's g5 stays closed
and my night probably has to retreat I
can't get c3 and
you know the extra pond that black has
is certainly felt that's for sure to
passport it's well supported
yeah
just have to go in reverse it's not fun
and there's another pond that's falling
and then take that and just scoop that
guy out okay
jeetu
I thought the night going here would be
more dangerous getting into have to but
either way I think it's still fantastic
for black
I need a miracle
maybe my opponent slips up
hope for here this is gone directively
h5 preparing meet Bishop g2 with Knight
to g4
I want to play here anyhow I don't I
don't think he's serving up a good
enough role being on g2 at this stage
you know let's just get them here and
it's going to be flushed
in Reverse
and
[Music]
pieces on the board maybe I sacrifice I
feel like I'll need to sacrifice
let's take once here my Knights and a
pin
at the brook
why is he going to go
this is my big block hater my big block
hater
uh h5 could still be played
g4 but still this undermining the ff4
point I think my knight will have to
return to d3 fh v is played
hmm
actually cuz I have pressure on the d5
nine actually have an edge on the clock
straightaway
being force f4 could be
I with g4 at least
just got to get a quick move in
and
now what do I do I guess we'll go here
I'm playing on three ranks
it's not fun
okay
hmm
and see
forty-three seconds
yeah I guess we'll play g4
this is collapsing losing the exchange
some kind of chaos get my queen out of a
check
they could just
what they go for
hmm
bishop here is a threat
actually one move sooner I have one good
piece by night
that's it
I'll take that and try to play this
position out it's actually not so clear
maybe it is after that
and I think I have
try this
in Poland game
should have never been the
close
got to take that
this guy
now winning
huh
and I could do this
Wow lucky dog I forgot I could do
multiple pre moves
jeez
and with this line
nothing
I don't know how to think with this it's
a that was such a terrible game on
Mayans a a the B form of
I need to do something about b4 and they
undermined my Center I didn't see that
they were going to be picking up upon
and it was an 88 move game and I think
for what like 90 for 90 percent of it
I'm just completely lost
really bad game
yeah we're going to just dive right into
it let me bring up the engine
well now actually before I bring up the
engine I have to do something different
right around well first of all I don't
know if I should even play King to H one
don't know if that's really necessary
maybe and just invest a move with a
three stabilize my night
yeah you know what something I could
just share quickly with a three I think
what might have kept me from doing that
is mmm I don't know why I was thinking
this but you know if your Castle
queenside you wouldn't want to play a3
but of course I'm not counseled
queenside this is important and this is
time well spent let's say if I'm playing
a tree and I'm counseled on the
queenside then it's easier for black to
rip open lines on the queenside and
attack my King I need to invest this
move I believe
stabilize my night and you know I don't
have to jump in here because things
completely changed not just lots of a
pond but the changing of the structure
and just has a complete domino effect on
my position
oh yeah I should be playing a three
probably just right now at this point
get an a3 Bishop to b7 and then and then
I could go with the Bishop f3 Bishop to
e3 Queen 81 rook to d1 so everything is
kind of pointing out first stabilizing
the knight and then these earlier ideas
I think right around the point my
opponent Lanford b4 I I was you know
eyeing up these possibilities of Queen
g3 in a capture and a capture on h6 I
don't think age 6 was correct but I
didn't have any time to take advantage
of that because of how things changed in
the center kicking off everything
kicking off with before so just one
little move here and things would have
been much different you know I think I
would have had a nice play rook a to d1
drift the Queen over here Bishop to e3
maybe yeah
Bishop e3 Queen e1 rook to d1 Queen g3
whoops Queen g3 and then already black
has to be concerned about the captures
and Bishop takes pawn
yeah well I would probably have to do
this as well reply to Bishop to b7 so
something like maybe this here here
Bishop f3 this seems pretty natural
clean her Bishop to e3 first maybe clean
here it's making some natural looking
moves there's even stuff like this that
black could try but uh already at this
point
to take and then take here
the bishop one thing that I do know is
from my minimal experience on the white
end is that the bishop is
pretty well placed
the Queen on g3 you know there isn't
this type of night maneuver night h5
forking the Queen and f4 so he watches
over that and also a potential
liberating d5 break by black
now this is a setup I
down for bottom I didn't have time to do
that I needed to stabilize my Queen
night first and foremost but let's have
a look at it with the engine and see
what more we can maybe take away from
this very lucky when okay this is where
I want to be so let's see
the computer is just saying play a three
you dummy
stabilizer Knights don't lose control of
the center so easily
right around here what did I do
I'm gonna ship to e3 it's already not a
fan of Bishop to e3 let's to go with a
four I think it popped up a four eight
three maybe for a second I guess I could
go in for a 4 B 4 95 right now I'm not
going to be losing a pawn you know this
is
but I'm I think I was just in the future
try my luck with a three first
d7
that this could be so bad
first Bishop to d7 just trying to get a
feel for this ok Queen the e1 it's not
giving me any advantage but rook c8
now f
okay so what was I leaning it are
leaning towards clean g3 so maybe black
is close to having to go with some
sacrifice like this because this is now
pretty serious this idea to take and
then take on h6 I am pinning the g7 pon
this would make for an interesting game
you know damage the queenside structure
giving up the exchange picking up an
important center pond
it wants to go back here yeah this is a
this would be an interesting position
clearly very unbalanced killed queenside
structure two to zero in the center
okay
interesting
duh yeah it didn't happen like that did
it I don't know ireon esteem no what
more there is to go over with this one
because once I played this and you know
once you go with a3 once more after
Queen to e1 is this sequence now yeah
they found the right sequence there
before
and yeah Bishop takes Knight I can be
captured and then II for
your stuff up on
I guess I have a little bit of
compensation it's not a full pond being
that I have the bishop hair but yeah
this is this is just dead I don't know I
think it just is worse from here on out
I had nine lives in this game
to growing advantage I don't think
there's ever a moment where I had a way
forward until it got down to a bullet
mode
yikes
to always be at least - too many kills
available the H what was it there for a
second now it's still - -
everything's fine with the well black is
doing dua something here it was a pretty
big drop in the evaluation
how long she just sacrifice here Knight
takes c3 and on pawn takes rook takes
rook takes and then this pawn marches ah
yeah so I guess a little bit was given
up by black when they replied with what
is pretty natural to just kind of duck
from this attack but
straightforward is this that's a killer
and I'm not even close to getting it
their King again any any any attempt to
initiate some pawn capture is just meant
with g5 and things get shut down and I
think black is even more secure by
having my pawn here and things kind of
all locked up fixed static etc so that
would have killed me plenty of other
kills I imagine okay not as bad
evaluation rise right around here but h4
is breaking down this and do they have
something sooner now okay
you know clean is just improving
improving some more and now I need to
play h4 you see one
and we're at this point where I have to
where i play h3 to stop a Knight g4 move
and then later I have to do this so I
stopped h4 so that f4 isn't falling
that's tough this is this is almost
equal to resigning the night getting
into g4 and then f2 at some point so
it's just completely gone I don't know
what more to say
yeah plenty of kills
this is like the one point where I
started to get have some hope believe it
or not when I was down material because
I felt like things are you know my kit
and my queen isn't going to be
challenged so so soon and you know this
pawn isn't going to be rolling I could
rely upon the bishop
but yeah they got the Queens off they
gave up a pawn that's fine
and yeah I don't know they just kind of
let me back in with this end game as it
got into Bullitt mode giving up the
center point and having my bishop locked
in
so completely winning
I thought they would play rook to f6 and
then just go here and give up another
pond
eggs and then whoops I came together
once
the king is here
my king never gets active this pond
doesn't even get to get rolling and the
rip could just do whatever target my
pond so I thought that that's the
direction they would go in
taking a page out of
doing similar like what they did here
giving up the clean getting more
exchanges in giving up a pond for it but
you know the Queen's are off and I
thought they would do similar here with
the rook when I played King to f3 but
now I'm kind of creeping back into the
ball game here
you go over here and try to pick him up
this is still winning for black but
after this maybe it starts to get a bit
tricky because they give up the d4
square to my king king d4 and now it's
not so easy
King there and now wow this is the point
where I'm now winning move 57 Wow
position and this guy's really fast was
it always winning from this point on
yeah it's it's gone
it's a W for white from that point on
but yeah
okay well I was clearly very lucky in
this one I'll have to go with that small
a3 move it's important
clearly my Center collapsed you saw it
in action
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video I hope you're
having a great day and I will catch you
soon that is all for now take care bye
you